То є майстерня мого діда,
а я був бідний-неприкаяний,
і не мав своєї майстерні.
Тут просто була можливість попрацювати,
бо на маленькому столику, де тепер лежать
скульптури, які тут робляться,
все решта я поки що окупував лірами.
Але то так, зараз є можливість — то я таке роблю.
Я можу довго розказувати всякі байки:
ой, я колись у дитинстві почув ліру,
і вона закралась мені в душу,
і я після того 16 років не міг думати,
що я зможу на ній грати.
Насправді був такий прикол: я був малий
і мене мама завела на концерт
як виявилося, Василя Нечепи — він грав на лірі.
Словом, я нічого не пам'ятаю
з того концерту!
Я пам'ятаю, що звук був дуже прикольний.
І то було моє перше таке несвідоме знайомство з лірою.
А вже свідомо чого я почав робити?
Я хотів зробити собі...
Купити було трохи дорого...
То було в три рази дорожче,
ніж я зараз роблю на продаж.
І я вирішив зробити собі сам,
бо я, бачте, скульптор, крутий пацан,
і я вмію з деревом працювати.
Я зробив отаку ліру.
Поки я її робив, пішла слава, що я вже майстер.
І до мене прийшов замовник купляти цю ліру.
Він спробував на ній пограти
і сказав, що це повне гімно, і того купляти не буде.
І так у мене почалася робота з лірами.
Потім я навчився, як її вистроїти, і я її таки продав!
Потім я навчився робити такі ліри
і виміняв назад, бо це — перший інструмент!
Ось так!
П'ятдесят перша...
Я сам у шоці!
В 2014 році я зробив десь, може, десять...
А в цьому році я вже не знаю, скільки зробив.
Але мене пре!
У мене спочатку була дуже страшна бойня з самим
собою, бо отакі штуки мене більше пре робити.
Типу в плані візуальному: ти береш,
колеш дровеняку, форму виводиш, як скульптор.
Але в процесі роботи я зрозумів, що для звуку,
а музичний інструмент — то є механізм,
краще для нього — це якась одна модель
і її постійне вдосконалення.
Ще я думав, що це — занудство, це як скрипкові
майстри роблять однакові скрипки ціле життя.
Виявляється — ні.
Якщо говорити про принципи, то ліра —
дуже цікавий інструмент.
І її навіть клас говорить сам за себе:
це — фрикційний інструмент.
Фрік!
Чого «фрік»? Тому що тут поєднуються
різні системи звуковидобування.
У нас є смичок у вигляді колеса.
[налаштовує інструмент]
Він у нас...
Зараз треба зробити, щоб воно ще грало.
[грає на інструменті]
Є смичок, а є клавіші і клавіші, по суті,
якщо в гітарі ми дотуляємо струну до ладів,
то тут ми лади дотуляємо до струни.
[грає на інструменті]
Цікаво, що в Україні фактично немає жодної ліри,
яка була би схожа одна на іншу.
Я в який музей не зайду,
в різних містах, областях,
де я був, там щоразу якась інша модифікація тої ліри.
Вони всі дуже цікаві і суперавтентичні.
Мене якраз це дуже перло, але в процесі роботи
я зрозумів, що треба розробляти модель,
і довго й нудно її втовкмачувати.
Можна дуже довго про історію лірників,
лірництва говорити,
тому що там є свої приколи: таємна мова,
і те, що вони були сліпі,
мали все одно свою ієрархію,
таємні устияновські книги.
Тобто збір законів, який передавався між
лірниками, кобзарями і старцями з вуст у вуста.
І вони всі по тому уставу жили.
Таємна мова, про яку всі, наприклад, думають,
що слово «лох» — це з якоїсь зони.
А насправді «лох» —
це «простий чоловік» на лірницькій мові.
На либійській, скажемо так,
я все під лірників підганяю.
Воно все має настільки гарний шарм,
що дуже мені імпонує.
Ти не просто робиш інструменти,
а вони мають свою історію.
Традиційні дерев'яні відповідають за висоту ноти,
тобто його можна звернути туди-сюди
і підстроїти певну ноту.
І коли ти виставляєш ноту на такій традиційній лірі,
то ти можеш підряд грати будь-що
і воно все буде «в тему».
Ясна річ, що є ноти, мелодії і так далі.
Але факт того, що там не треба сильно думати:
чи там зараз дієз, чи ні.
От я зараз вчуся грати псальми так,
щоби розслабилася рука,
адже переважно сліпці грали на ньому.
Я вчуся взагалі не дивитися на клавіатуру
і відчувати її мануально.
У мене зараз такий експеримент — сам собі роблю.
Як на мене, не можна так казати:
«Це все брєд, чуваки не мали грошей
і робили з чого мали,
і це не має право на існування, наше діло — еволюція!»
Але це все історія, це підвалини наші,
на яких ми стоїмо.
Тому щось таке доказувати — це теж повний бред!
Але з іншої сторони: «Має бути тільки так!»
Добре! Окей!
Сам факт того, що в Україні в мене
не перестають замовляти ліри,
це вже показує, що ми кудись рухаємось.
А іноземці теж купляють, тому що я роблю
з того матеріалу, який у нас тут є.
І можна, по суті, поїхати в Брюховичі
чи позбирати в парку.
І я маю дуже дешевий матеріал і завдяки цьому
по суті демпінгую європейських виробників.
Я беру простотою, тому що ті інструменти,
які я роблю, скажімо, такого формату,
то ти якщо освоїв їх, ти береш інструмент
за 5000 євро якогось європейського майстра,
то без проблем, переходиш на новий рівень.
То в мене уніфікована клавіатура за всіма західноєвропейськими інститутами.
Цікаво, що в цій справі не відчувається конкуренції,
тому що нема такого натовпу замовників,
щоби ставити це на комерційний возик,
фабрику робити чи щось таке.
Круті майстри вирізняються тим, що в них
дорогі інструменти і черга на кілька років уперед.
Я пробував спішити, пробував удосконалювати,
у виробничому плані ставити на комерційніші
штуки, а воно якось не дуже виходить.
Або з мене поганий бізнесмен!
[сміється]
В мене постійно є помічники, підрядники,
які мені щось допомагають робити.
Мені, наприклад, осі виточував чувак з Дніпродзержинська.
І він пише мені: «Слухай, я тут так напоров,
воно всьо в мене таке криве».
А я думаю «Що криве?
Я зараз покажу, які я робив осі».
Ще на дрельці болгаркою вирізав.
[сміється]
Вісь може бути крива...
От зараз у мене вже буде
наступний етап: коли вже все в мене є,
мені треба на самій лірі проточити колесо,
бо якщо зараз взяти його —
воно таке криве, їздить в різні сторони.
А я потім чіпляю корбу, сідаю з ножем,
і проточую на самому інструменті колесо так, що
вісь може всередині хилитатися в різні сторони,
а колесо буде собі рівнесенько іти.
Я собі маю отакий пунктик:
маю зробити хоча би триста.
Є оця сумна історія з тим розстріляним з'їздом.
Я так розумію, що то, звичайно, себе тішити тим,
що ти якось доклався до відродження.
Але я не скажу, що я тут
щось сильно відроджую, я просто продовжую.
Але я вважаю, що якщо зроблю триста,
то місія виконана буде з моєї сторони.
Тому що вже я бачу, що з'явилися ще майстри.
Тоді, коли я починав, то був тільки
кобзарський цех і ще один майстер.
А зараз я дивлюсь, що чуваки
з'являються і починають тим займатися.
Уже більше їх робить.
Я вважаю, що я долучився, а то вже час покаже.